This isn't looking good at all. What was supposed
to be an easy day hike, is quickly turning
into a life-threatening situation. One of
your top priorities is to get a fire going
before nightfall, but all you've got with
you is a bag lunch and an empty water bottle.
This is a challenge that's going to require
a little creativity. You're going to have
to light this fire, with your pee!
For this project you're gonna need some
of that special yellow liquid, and the timing
is great because with all that water you drank,
nature is calling. You can use a container
like your water bottle to collect as much
as possible. Now, that's really not a lot,
and it looks like you're still a little dehydrated,
but you're gonna have to make it work.
When you flip the bottle over and attempt
the water bottle trick from a previous video,
it doesn't seem to be working. And that's
because you don't have enough fluid in your
bottle. You try removing the label to see
if that helps, but it's not making much of
a difference. Ok, time to check your lunch
bag to see what other resources you have.
There's a bag of celery sticks that could
be useful. But here's something even better…
…you wrapped your apple with a plastic wrap.
Perfect! Carefully remove the wrapper, making
sure not to rip it, and now you're gonna
need some rocks. When you place these rocks
in a circle, they've formed a crude concave
mold. The rocks help form the wrapper into
a bowl shape, and now you can add the liquid.
When it's filled to the edges, grab all the
sides, and hold them together at the top,
making this into a little liquid pouch. Twisting
this pouch, while holding at the top, helps
remove any air and seals the liquid inside.
When you twist the excess plastic around your
middle finger like a ring, then wrap it around
the base to hold it in place, the pressure
can be adjusted, and you've got yourself a
great little liquid lens that's easy to use!
It's magnifying very well, so time to test
it out on some tinder. One of the unneeded
pages from your map should work perfectly,
so focus the sunlight on the darkest ink you
can find, because this will absorb the heat.
It's incredible how quickly this starts smoking,
and where there's smoke, there's a hope of
fire! A hole is burning in the paper now,
and when it's about the size of a quarter
it's pretty well self sustaining. Without
wasting any time, try adding layers of dry
grass, and blowing gently to add some air.
It's getting hot, and smoking quite a bit,
so just blow a little stronger, and success!
You've got a flame. Now get that to a place
you can build your fire up, and it's finished!
You just lit a fire with your pee. Well there's
a little trick most people will never have
to use, but might be good to know just in
case. If you liked this project, perhaps you'll
like some of my others. Check them out at
www.thekingofrandom.com